yo what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd here with one of the
last unboxing videos for a while um this
uh this is um an ifrogs unboxing
actually as you can see by the title
but i say that because i've just been so
busy with uh school work and homework
and all that stuff
i know the school year is winding down
so this uh obviously this phase won't
last very long but
i've had so many i have so many essays
and everything and stuff like that to
write
so this is basically going to be one of
the last videos in like a week i might
upload one or two more tutorials and
possibly a review video i'm not sure yet
so look out for those but please rate
five stars if you want these to keep
going
um this is an unboxing video of the
ifrog's fallout over ear customizable
headphones
and
the review video may or may not happen
because i was actually considering doing
a video comparing these to the d33s that
i received from ifrogs which are in ear
and noise isolating earbuds not over ear
earphones
so um basically let's get into the
package
like i said earlier these are
customizable headphones
so you can choose if you actually go to
the link in the description which is the
ifrog's website you can go uh look at
those fallouts and you can actually
choose your colors and your uh your
styles and designs and stuff like that
for the fallouts
so um
yeah let's just get into the package and
i actually can see what
colors i chose for the fallouts and
there's a little bit of shipping
information in here no biggie
nothing else in the bags you can tell
so uh this is actually i have to say
about ifrogs their service is extremely
extremely fast uh they got back to me
within with the emails within like hours
of when i emailed them uh the order was
shipped really quickly and i got to me
really really fast so um
anyway these are the fallouts as you can
see these are um over here obviously
earphones i did customize these to be
red and black basically which happen to
be my favorite colors and so let's just
get right into the box you make or the
bag whatever you want to call it these
you may notice look strikingly similar
to the d33s in that the headphones were
on top
and the a little uh little accessories
kit on the bottom so let's see what's
down in there
so i think this is just the earbuds yeah
this is just the earbuds a little design
on this piece of plastic or paper here
and then we have the fallouts so let's
go
the fallouts do use a 3.5 millimeter
headphone jack and they are you know
just standard over-the-ear uh headphones
not noise canceling or anything
uh stereo headphones so let's see if i
can uh get these out without making too
much noise here we go
all right so on the back of the uh the
actual packaging it doesn't say much
about the earphones obviously you can go
check out their website in the
description which has a ton of
information about these particular
headphones i don't need the knife
anymore
but yeah this is basically the
headphones you can see uh these are um
the fallout series this particular
design right here was customizable um
the 3.5 millimeter headphone jack
obviously
i don't know exactly how long the cord
is but we'll find that out later
and that's basically it they do look
like a very sturdy solid build i like
the colors that i picked they look quite
nice
and uh basically i can't wait to get you
guys with a comparison video between
these much more portable d33s and the
over ear powerful louder fallout so i'll
have like a big compare contrast video
probably in
one or two weeks depending on how really
busy i am i have finals coming again
coming up and everything
so anyway thanks for watching this video
guys this is just a quick unboxing and
first impressions of the fallouts and
well i will catch you guys later and
hopefully if you haven't already rate
this video five stars and leave comments
about what you think and that's
basically it thanks for watching guys
peace